1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ans 2 100 200 300
ça fait donc 300 jours que je relève le
défi de vous faire une vidéo chaque jour
depuis le premier jour pour parler
directement ou indirectement de
mentalisme et aujourd'hui pour cette 3
centièmes vidéo il faut que je vous
fasse un cadeau que je vous parle d'un
truc un peu gros vous avez toujours dit
que quand donc menthe à l'eau oui
mantallot j'aime pas sûr non vous n'êtes
pas obligé de tous vous sentir concernés
quand je dis menthe à l'eau je disais
donc je vous ai toujours dit que j'avais
une approche pédagogique un petit peu de
cette chaîne c'est à dire que je vous
donnais des choses un peu étape par
étape pour faire toujours de plus en
plus gros au fur et à mesure de l'année
et si vous avez suivi les vidéos un
petit peu dans l'ordre vous vous rendez
compte que c'est le cas chaque vidéo
s'appuie ni plus ni moins sur
d'anciennes vidéos jusque là c'est très
clair et bien aujourd'hui je vous
explique comment deviner précisément un
prénom auquel pense une personne ne m
étonne déjà fait ça va bien sur le
chaîne wii est presque deux fois en plus
sauf qu'à chaque fois vous demandiez à
la personne de choisir quelqu'un qui
était dans la pièce par exemple et vous
déduisez à quel personnel penser là on
parle de penser un prénom est de trouver
ce prénom
autant vous dire que cette vidéo elle
fait partie des vidéos en mode c'est du
lourd mec qui a eu sur cette chaîne vous
m'avez souvent demandé comment faire ça
ici je vous avais donné à l'époque la
réponse telle que je vais vous la donne
est là maintenant vous n'auriez pas pu
en tout cas je pense apprécié la manière
de faire et ça vous aurez sûrement
découragé alors que c'est tout à fait
viable
l'idée donc de demander à une personne
de penser à un prénom ça on l'avait
compris de l'éclair d'une part de le
dire personne que ce soit juste dans sa
tête et vous vous allez devoir extraire
cette info pour ça il vous faut une
pince à crabes où quelques astuces de
mentalisme et un bon sens de la logique
vous choisissez c'est un peu comme vous
la première étape elle consiste oui je
me suis un peu fatiguée elle consiste à
déterminer quel est le rapport entre la
personne à qui vous essayez de faire ça
et là personne à qui elle pense vous
allez lui demander de réfléchir si c'est
quelqu'un de sa famille quelqu'un au
travail
quelqu'un parmi ces mbs que et ça ne
l'est pas précisé vous devez lui
demander de penser à quelqu'un qu'elle
connaît quelqu'un qui existe dans son
entourage quelqu'un à qui elle parle de
temps en temps ou très régulièrement une
fois vous avez déterminé ça je vous
expliquerai comment après vous devez
déterminer plus précisément la personne
c'est quelqu'un de sa famille est ce que
c'est son frère sa soeur son oncle sa
tante son père sa mère son grand-père sa
grand-mère trouvé ça c'est dans ses amis
est ce que c'est son meilleur ami
cissé au travail est ce que son patron
c'est un collègue c'est très important
parce que la troisième étape du
processus va être de trouver l'âge
approximativement de la personne pascal
erre dans les quarante ans dans les
cinquante ans dans les trente ans dans
les vingt ans dans les dix ans dans les
1 an c'est possible tout est possible ça
vous donnera déjà une bonne image parce
qu'en faisant tout ça vous aurez à peu
près l'âge de la personne son rapport
avec le personnel qui vous parlais et le
sexe de la personne
on avance sherlock ensuite vous allez
chercher à déterminer les premières
lettres du prénom de la personne
alors pour ça je vous rappelle je
voulais mettre par ici qu'on a fait une
vidéo pour trouver à quelle lettre pense
une personne vous allez simplement
utiliser ce processus pour trouver une
deux ou trois lettres et en utilisant
une technique de cul berland 10 mhz par
exemple comme je vous l'expliquais aussi
sur la vidéo sur le cul perlant 10 mhz
vous allez pouvoir déterminer le nombre
de syllabes que compose le prénom avec
toutes ces informations on va passer aux
stocks reding si vous savez que la
personne est une femme que c'est la mère
de la personne à qui vous parlez vous
connaissez l'âge de la personne qui est
en face de vous si la personne pense à
sa mère et que la personne que vous avez
en face de vous on va dire 35 ans
donc ça veut dire que sa mère entre 25
et 35 ans de plus qu'elle en moyenne que
vous déterminé que la première lettre du
prénom c'est un thème que la deuxième
c'est un as
il ya de fortes probabilités que le
prénom de la mère soit martin parce qu'à
cette génération là à cet âge là les
prénoms féminins commençant par m à
indique que statistiquement c'était
martine le prénom le plus donné mais
plus de ça vous pouvez affiner avec le
nombre de syllabes ou des lettres
supplémentaires évidemment le travail
préalable à faire c'est de se renseigner
de potasse est un peu en stock reding le
travail sur les prénoms générationnel
masculin et féminin donc des différentes
générations parce que sinon j'aurais pas
dit mot générationnel évidemment il va
falloir appliquer ça a une culture où
plusieurs cultures si vous voulez le
faire par exemple tu me fais ça avec un
prénom indien moi je suis foutu c'est
terminé tu vas le plus simple pour
commencer c'est quand même de faire avec
les prénoms de sa propre culture dans sa
propre langue
ok tout ça c'est plutôt pas mal c'est un
peu fou mais c'est pas mal mais comme on
fait donc pour trouver famille et c'est
bien c'est là qu'interviennent la
lecture des signes non verbaux dont je
vous ai parlé plusieurs fois ce soit
dans le détection de mensonges dans
l'astuce pour trouver à qui pensez une
personne dans la pièce dans l'astuce
pour trouver à quel film pensé une
personne tous ces éléments là sont des
outils pour vous pour comprendre dans un
plan séquence et à quoi pense une
personne vous allez comprendre à quel
point toutes ces vidéos là étaient des
outils ayant pour but entre autres
d'atteindre la 300e vidéo pour vous
faire cette révélation je sais qu'il y
aura deux types de réactions à cette
vidéo ce qu'ils diront ah bon mais c'est
tout c'est que ça est ce qu'ils vont
comprendre en fait le petit bonbon que
c'est en fait c'est sûrement un des
trucs les plus personnelles que je
rêvais nul sur ma chaîne alors c'est pas
une méthode miracle vous avez vu il faut
aussi un peu de culot faut un peu de
connaissances générales sur le stock
reding pour les prénoms pour les
différentes générations hommes et femmes
il faut avoir plusieurs cordes à son arc
pour être capable de déterminer un âge
approximatif une relation avec quelqu'un
et ça quelle que soit l'information que
je cherche de toute manière je séquence
les choses par des choses très binaire
est ce que ça fait partie des amis ou de
la famille ou du travail
une fois que j'ai la réponse je vais
creuse un peu plus loin au final même si
vous êtes juste à côté du prénom ce
serait quand même très perturbant parce
que ce sera quasiment le prénom j'espère
que vous apprécierez toute cette
démarche là qu'il ya dans cette vidéo
pour moi c'est beaucoup mieux que je
vous donne aujourd'hui personnellement
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas si elle vous
plus de vous abonner également à la
chaîne puisqu'il reste encore 66 vidéo
jusqu'à voir la fin de l'année jusqu'à
avant le 31 décembre
il ya encore des vidéos de l'année
prochaine rassurez-vous et le mental
blog vous dis à demain 17h ciao
tout ça
palau